welcome to this video playing us spin
doors from Turkey okie dokie and let's
play this screen pawn opening and I had
this only recently I'll talk about quick
play and it wasn't so great i really had
some at some problems i don't remember
exactly what it was how this unfolded
maybe it was like that i don't know why
it has some some interesting play him my
development is not really great so what
is this him can I take and go Bishop c5
maybe he's got not be five though anyway
I shook took too long so night b5 yeah i
was thinking Teague and Bishop c5 cannot
be that bad maybe it is bad okay take
and to keep that point for the moment
how bad can that be it can be bad go
queen bee six before maybe input p5 is
hanging let's do it um before can I go
queen bee five I probably can okay it
goes with the Queen to a form but it's
the deer taking on a 7 or mmm one
problem is if I go before I don't really
have a clear don't have a clear reply
lyman the other castle he goes before
this is what I'm trying to say I don't
have them I don't have a square to go to
maybe night efore for Bishop t6 or
night age five maybe night h5m not easy
be 49 f 4 BC 592 check that that I can
definitely play and I don't think it's
so bad just a bit strange
that's I didn't expect that at all how
can this be good for wide and 4 is weak
and I'm a pawn up and five maybe
something like this no
so what does this actually mean I can
take f4 okay why not now maybe over here
for Bishop f6 it's not a bad spot yeah
of course you still has this pressure
against the a pawn
Bishop f6 and then night if I have
something like that I don't know Knight
f6 is also an interesting move not quite
sure maybe do this hard to tell they
don't want to fall to the fall too far
behind on the clock the most likely
scenario for me not winning this guy's
is some something with the clock yeah
night g4s also move very interesting one
let's do this it takes a 78 @ x f2
e 7 and f 2 hanging
masum tactics are something like on the
long diagonal if i take it seven with
the bishop esat-6 so rather murky it is
this immediately I was thinking night f2
should be strong come on or is there
something that I don't see at all let's
do this where green tea eggs and queen
fo also was pretty strong or queen it
wrong yeah anyway I have to be quick
threatening night age 3 with made so
Scott doesn't doesn't have many
opportunities so now i can check him can
play Queen d6 as a simple solution
threatening mate on h2 and threatening
the night
yeah what what now maybe checking us is
even better on f2 checking and then
taking yourself and you can take on a
eight hmm what's the best way to do it
Jack and this is pretty strong
threatening again the double check on
age three and still everything is
hanging a seven is hanging and the rook
is potentially also hanging so check
check check check let's let's grab stuff
now and that's a piece white resigns
okay yeah that was a messy game out of
the opening I'm not really sure they're
playing this right anyway antiques 97
yeah White's development is pretty good
from structural point of view black is
in very good shape but the development
is not good so difficult difficult to
assess 95 and took I wonder maybe I may
I should just take only five I don't
know not before now it's got home and I
went down yeah it's still it's still
interesting I think what probably has
good chances my bishop doesn't have many
squares Queen a form and this was
necessary the engine wants to do this
interesting can I now go here before a
stronger because of this
and that's not good for me well this is
probably a mistake then but difficult
difficult stuff yeah still I would have
expected him to just put the bishop back
this is wrong I believe I don't don't
believe in that very much structure it's
just too bad this okay counselor you 49
f6 yeah still very messy position Jack
he went here this is probably a mistake
yeah yeah and it's that's losing
actually that's a good move because now
he has to deal with 94 94 and this is
losing straightaway yeah and I played I
played this it wins but I should have
had Authority for a moment because this
is pretty convincing threatening night f
to end the mate this is win as well
which simply thinking for a moment
Buddha chan been better and this yeah
it's sad check it was ok I think I mean
if you see one thing that wins just play
it don't think twice or three times if
you have something better well thanks
for watching